angioplastía transluminal percutánea no
cardiaca
un cirujano realizará una angioplastía
transluminal percutánea no cardíaca o
ncp tea para restaurar el flujo
sanguíneo en una arteria obstruida por
la placa aterosclerótica los depósitos
de grasa denominados placas
ateroscleróticas pueden acumularse en
las arterias estrechando el pasillo e
interfiriendo con el flujo sanguíneo
esta obstrucción arterial se denomina
estenosis el flujo insuficiente de
sangre a un tejido generalmente causa
dolor una angioplastía transluminal
percutánea no cardíaca se realiza
únicamente cuando su condición no ha
respondido a las opciones menos
invasivas de tratamiento como cambios en
el estilo de vida y medicamentos para
empezar el procedimiento se le ubicará
en una mesa equipada con un fluoroscopio
un fluoroscopio es capaz de tomar
imágenes de rayos x de varias partes del
cuerpo desde múltiples ángulos
el médico adormecer a la piel alrededor
de donde se insertará el catéter
debido a que las arterias de la pierna
son de más fácil acceso la arteria
femoral en la ingle sirve como sitio de
inserción en la mayoría de los casos
inicialmente el médico tendrá acceso a
la arteria insertando una aguja hueca a
través de la cual pasa el catéter de
globo con filtro mirando a la pantalla
fluoroscópica el médico avanzará
cuidadosamente el catéter hasta
posicionarlo en la arteria que va a ser
tratada e inyectar a un colorante
especial este colorante permite que el
fluoroscopio tome imágenes de rayos x-
llamados angiogramas que le permite al
médico identificar la ubicación exacta
de las obstrucciones luego el médico
moverá el catéter hasta que el globo
desinflado en su punta se encuentre
posicionado en el lugar de la estenosis
luego inflando y desinflando rápidamente
el globo
el médico empujará cuidadosamente la
placa y la pared del vaso hacia un lado
restableciendo parcialmente el flujo
sanguíneo se puede repetir este
procedimiento para cualquier obstrucción
adicional en algunos casos el médico
puede colocar un stent
qué es una malla de alambre que
permanece en la arteria para mantenerla
abierta para desarrollar este
procedimiento
el médico colocará un stent hundido
sobre el globo desinflado en la punta
del catéter cuando se infla el globo
el stent se expande y encaja en su lugar
al final del procedimiento el médico
retirará el catéter a través del sitio
original de la inserción después del
procedimiento se colocará una venda de
presión en el lugar de inserción del
catéter y se le pedirá que permanezca
atendido para prevenir hemorragias será
monitoreado cuidadosamente en el área de
recuperación para asegurarse de que el
fluido sanguíneo se mantiene a través de
la arteria afectada a la mayoría de los
pacientes se les da de alta el mismo día
de su procedimiento pero algunos
permanecen en el hospital entre uno y
dos días para observación